[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم بايجاز من غرفه اخبار
الجزيره مرحبا بكم قوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي تقتل فلسطينيين خلال اقتحامها
مخيمين في طولكرم في وقت اقتحم فيه مئات
المتطرفين المسجد الاقصى على اثر ذلك دعت
حركه حماس الى مواصله الانتفاضه دفاعا عن
المقدسات وقالت الرئاسه الفلسطينيه ان
تصعيد الاحتلال هو ترجمه لخطاب نتنياهو في
الامم المتحده مجلس الامن القومي الارميني
يعلن احباط محاوله انقلابيه المجلس قال في
بيان انه اعتقل ثمانيه اشخاص ضمن تنظيم
كان اعضائه يخططون لاستخدام اسلحه وذخائر
للاستيلاء على السلطه هذا وقد وصلت الدفعه
الاولى من ارمن كارباخ الى ارمينيا في حين
اتهم لابروف القياده الارمينيه بتاجيج
الصراع تجدد التوتر في كوسوفو بعد مقتل
شرطي في هجوم مسلح على دوريه امنيه شماليه
الاقليم السلطات القت بالمسؤوليه على
عصابات الجري المنظمه وقالت ان ذلك يتم
بدعم سياسي ومالي ولوجستي من مسؤولين في
بلجراليا اجمالي التبرعات لاحتواء الاثار
المترتبه على زلزال الحوز يصل الى مليار
دولار وفق احصاءات غير رسميه حيث ساهمت في
هذه التبرعات مؤسسات وشركات محليه مغربيه
يذكر ان تكلفه اعاده اعمار المناطق التي
ضربها الزلزال تقدر باثني عشر مليار دولار
الى اللقاء